this one's not really a hot take but the
Jets are going to win the Super Bowl I
really want them to come to spread three
games over 500 is a winning season for
the Jets 2023 Super Bowl champion New
York Jets no doubt about it we're on a
die-hard Jets fan 49ers and jets in the
Super Bowl 24-17 Jets win CJ Mosley as
the MVP Amelia Packers Fan so I think
Jordan love is going to prove everyone
wrong Jets worse than the Patriots this
year nothing new because they're used to
losing my son's an idiot 16-1 Aaron
Rodgers MVP I like the Jeeps Jason Super
Bowl and I'm going to be honest with you
I'm not that excited all the hype about
Rogers and the Jets go back to being the
same old I'm super excited my
prediction is the Jets will go
make the playoffs make it to the wild
card but they will lose